this is a production of Cornell
University
hi so you guys are all about to go into
finals but right
I was kind of impressed that you're here
thank you
and I got a total load of crap dumped on
me when I left the farm today we're all
planting trees so we can all just be
glad that we're in this little cocoon
together for an hour how many of you
have heard of the Finger Lakes cider
house or let me start with how many have
you been to the Finger Lakes cider house
okay cool
how many have heard of Goodlife farm
haha that is a UH tur failure let me
just say of the loves of cider house on
so I'm going to start with that at that
point um I guess I'll tell you a little
bit of myself first um so my name is
Melissa med I graduated from Cornell in
2004 and I was the whatever you guys are
calling that position now the organic
farm coordinator at Cornell from 2008 to
2011 okay Betsy yeah
and during that time my husband and I
bought our farm we had spent a number of
years apprentice inform and just kind of
in 2007 something kind of like so that
doesn't actually sound that long from
2004 to 2007 we're like we're done
working for other people we can't
possibly do this another minute longer
and we're both really lucky to get a
really good job that were not like
apprenticeships in agriculture anymore
my husband was originally very well
trained carpenter and he became the
production manager at slug planet which
she heard of is like a great revolution
in energy efficiency for housing in
Tompkins County um and I got the jobs at
Bettina house and that was really
pivotal for us because we were
immediately able to get loans and buy a
piece of land so we spent a lot of time
looking for farm a farm a lot of time is
like super relative like I was 24 and he
are 25 and he was 21 and so like every
month that went
I felt like greater emergency so we came
back from an apprenticeship in December
of 2007 applied for these jobs like
somehow miraculously got them by January
of 2008 and then by March of 2008 we had
an offer and a piece of property and we
were like that don't so long oh my god
like what were we like oh this is just
agonizing we need to start farming right
now and then the funny thing was this is
the land we bought so there was this is
not on our property so there was no
there was no infrastructure at all and
it was it took till June to close who
put an offer in and Marchant took till
June to close and we put a little yurt
here those of you who have been there
maybe have heard of it or seen it but
it's kind of across this little creeks
we had to build it we felled some trees
and built a bridge and then we by the
time we closed like this entire farm was
planted to conventional wheat and
soybeans so that was it for us for the
year of having any control over our
property which was like a really
interesting and difficult experience
because we were coming coming at it with
these extreme I would say views about
the way we wanted to manage land and the
changes that we wanted to see and the
reason I'm kind of making so much fun of
our sense of time is that it's been over
the past ten years like expanded and
expanded because we wanted to have a
permaculture paradise so more hands who
knows what permaculture means does
anyone care to offer a definition I
certainly am NOT an expert and I kind of
started forgetting what I usually say
about it so does anyone else one throw
something out there agriculture that is
based on attorney electron based
agriculture so the crops that you grow
there so backwards are there like trees
or yeah I love writing so I'm going to
so actually there's like two things
going on there there's the concept and
then there's the tools right and what
you just said I would personally say as
a tool which is perennial agriculture do
you know what the concept is that it
goes with that well that's that's the
most common interpretation of
permaculture anyone else want to take a
stab at it I'm not like I hope you don't
feel like I just shot you down I made a
mistake once when I first met my husband
I was giving a talk on soil science and
we were brainstorming and he said
something that I thought was wrong and I
said no it is an extract of the entire
room and I can't believe we got married
but anyway so I won't do that promise
does anyone want to take stab just these
are really important for me so yeah
design approach for what was sustainable
yeah thank you
that's the big overarching one right I'm
just going to say life and then there's
three kind of like
little things that we like to say does
anyone know what they are they're very
codified in the permaculture looks kind
so earth care this is I had a very
embarrassing moment where I forgot one
of them fair share and people care does
anyone disagree with me did you ever
kind of okay so I think this is where
like a lot of permaculture lists end up
is that this is a this is a really
direct line in terms of tools and one
thing I'm excited to talk about is how
once your business gets more mature you
actually maybe start to feel like you
can address these things these other two
things but this is definitely where we
started so if you can imagine we're
sitting we were like camping basically
living in a yurt which we still live in
ten years later which is a problem under
this which is like you should have a
house after 10 years so we were watching
this farming system that we like very
vehement Lee just agreed with right like
I had has anyone heard of Cayuga pure
organics not yeah these things pass and
then we find out how old we are all
because no it was like hot [ __ ] you
could send here to call this so how you
get pure organics is where I met my
husband and it was a green farm that was
making really big waves in brook Tyndale
because they were vertically integrating
in the way that older grain farms used
to processing their own grain instead of
selling it to a much larger mill and it
was in green star and everyone was
trying to like figure out how to work
with it and I was one of the original
cleaners of beans there and you know
like Reva taquería would get these
incredible bags being
and then have to spend a lot of time
pulling the rocks out because we were
not that great at what we were doing
originally and so that was that was one
of those things that in farming that way
no that was a certified organic
operation anytime there was a rain event
like you can imagine for most of the
year that's like a ton of exposed soil
and it can be a really distressing thing
to be part of and witness and perpetuate
so I remember in 2000 so this is for a
full year we weren't able to get like
permanent ground cover on our property
and I'm not saying like I eat perennial
or I eat annual vegetables I eat annual
grains I'm not saying no I'm saying
that's not how we wanted a farm we
wanted to push the boundaries as much as
possible
of this because we were seeing that most
of the people practicing this we're
practicing it on a hobby scale under
definitely under five acres and mostly
under one acre and so we wanted to know
if it's like an actual farming system
that could be a pride apply to a broad
scale so this is a 69 acre parcel 45
acres of open fields and 24 acres of
woods and we felt like this is like this
great blank slate this from here to here
is Honeoye soil does anybody know very
much about that soil type it's the state
soil oh my God thank you for knowing
that it's delicious right like it's
actually a sweet soil a little bit
alkaline it's very deep and very lonely
lomi and incredibly rich and then from
here down as Cazenovia so to anyone know
anything about Cazenovia it was still a
really good Ag soil it doesn't really
nothing compares to honey way but um so
our two flagship sliders are now named
to those two things and in terms of the
failure of the tasting room to tell you
those things that you don't know about
our farm you don't know that that stuff
so we were we were thinking okay with
this great farm it's a really good base
we're going to show what 69 acres can do
in terms of perennial agriculture but
then we had to wait a year just to plant
the ground cover so in March of 20 2009
on there was a huge rain event and I
remember just standing out
so all the crafts have been harvested
there's very little residue and there
are no roots no living roots in the
ground and very you know like very few
even your like previous care roots and
this is like an 8% slope would you agree
Tom from here to here slippin down
towards how you like and you can do see
these does anyone know what these are
not Tom what yeah these are like the
dips in the farm yeah and this is where
can you see how they're even in this
time of year which you can see this is
like really early spring have dark green
layer like it's amazing what how much
less soil is on the top of these ridges
here than in these valleys here so we
our big goal was to stop that right away
and I remember in March of 2009 just
like totally freaking out like standing
here and watching all this topsoil go
this way I mean like what do I do like I
want to lie down and like put some straw
down like I'm a tiny little person and
this is 16 acres or 69 acres and like
there was nothing I could do and then
luckily by May we had gotten the whole
thing planted to grass and I ran into my
friend who is a grain farmer who has
spoken here and I will not say his name
and he was so so annoyed because it was
like I really wish you would have rented
your farm to me why you figured your
[ __ ] out and I was like well it's
already figured out that I know what I'm
doing and this is what I'm doing and we
have saved the planet so it was a very
successful moment to plant grass and
then quickly in succession let's see I
hope I made good so this is what it
looks like in in April of 2009 and then
so you remember this this is what it
basically looks like now I'm not like a
very excellent graphic designer this is
a PowerPoint mock-up and yeah I see that
it says 2013 on the top but I guess what
I'll say is we continue to plant trees
all the way down and the entire farm is
green and I just learned that there's
actually a new google shot so I probably
should have put that in there but
basically what you can see is
it the only part of our farm at this
point that remains in annual tillage
agriculture is right here
it's a flattest spot on the farm it's
six high tunnels five of which are
movable asleep all five of those have
three rotations each and otherwise
everything's covered in grass and
asparagus and we've been planting fruit
trees since 2009 2010 we plant asparagus
in 2009 and that was this project that
was like crazy like I felt like it was
in a desert right like like nothing
happening and now this is 2010 planting
trees and that's a team work looks like
I just want to show you this is this is
part of what it looks like now or
actually that's 2011 so those trees are
much bigger so it's green is covered in
trees it's it's got like some places
where there's a little bit of tillage
and that's done with horses um and at
the same time like do you think that
we've been able to I'm just looking for
some more pictures I've been able to
make a living off of this farm I see a
head shaking some of you who have
already heard this from me I think my
doom and gloom story I've been warned
not to be like too negative so one of
the problems I think you run into when
you have really big ideas and you you
think that you in in and of yourself
like our grand solution is that
sometimes you can really fail here and
the one thing about this farm I love my
farm so much I at this point we raise
beef cows we raise we have organic
asparagus organic peaches organic apples
organic Asian pears specialty greens
which showed you a picture of specialty
ginger which we make into a house-made
soda and then poultry sometimes and I
like love the place that the good life
farm is but the reality is that it'll be
like a whole other generation before
that farm is capitalized and that I find
challenging like more challenging every
year so like one of the things I
mentioned is like still living and
basically shack
and I think what a lot of people find
hilarious about that is that this I'll
come back to these I didn't know what
work
I forgot what we're gonna do this is our
building right and we built that
ourselves so we're like infinitely
capable of actually building a home and
I think one of the things that we have
constantly struggled against is in that
idea that we want to make the biggest
possible positive impact we realized
that we weren't able to be full-time on
our own operation with everything being
based in corneal agriculture and in some
ways like I would say cows our perennial
agriculture like we raise a cow-calf
herd so we're always working off of our
own mothers only so every year I have
one new mother to add to my herd and
that means one additional cow but
ideally like an operation that would
good cash flow sorry would be like 100
cows anyone want to take a guess at how
many I have in my painful years of
building my heart 18 come on yeah so
it's going to be like forever right so
we decided that we needed to vertically
integrate I did anyone here come to the
farmer ground and a Schnurr farm stock
or have heard from them before so those
guys are two of my best friends and
there are really important mentors in my
life and I think one of the things they
do for me really well is makes fun of me
like all the time
and they thought this was crazy but they
also got it but one of the things about
their vertical integration - did Greg
come with them did farmer ground flour
no okay
so there's Oscar farm very well run like
one of the best run organic grain farms
you're ever going to find incredible
crop rotation plan supporting the
beginning of former ground flour which
is a really high quality grain mill that
sources is designed to source locally
especially for master farms and then
wide awake bakery right
the difference is those are three
separate businesses run by three
separate owners one of the things that
we did was we try to verge
we integrate within our own operation so
at this point we've got good life farm
and it is really important that that's
the foundation every year we are able to
make a little bit more of our cider from
our own production but right now we're
only at 20 percent in a good year and
then we have a farm cidery which I
should have a farm winery license and
that is great because it means we can
take these apples that we're growing
organically and they look super gnarly
and also the variety is weird
like who here well you guys are really
unique crowd but you know like
Garlington mill Ellis better like dab
Manette our these are not terribly well
known varieties but they're great to
grow in an organic system and we again
like going back to like not only the
fact that it's perennial but how do you
want to manage your perennial
agriculture like what do you want your
rotation of inputs to be what do you
want the things that you have to
purchase to be I think that people tend
to assume that permaculture farms are
organic and that seems like a natural
assumption to me I still personally
think it's very important to be
certified if you're practicing organic
agriculture it's not something we should
be self certifying in my opinion because
it's really hard to do and takes a lot
of attention a lot of times people will
mix biodynamic swith with permaculture
and I think that's also a great mix as
you can see we it's sort of silly at
this point that we haven't certified
biodynamic because of the integration of
animals on our farm but we don't do the
preparation so we don't we don't do the
full thing and so we've got this farm
winery and it's justified by the
existence of our farm our farm but in
reality in New York State you could be a
farm winery or farm brewery without
producing a single piece of the
commodity yourself and apples are still
considered a commodity which in and of
itself is an incredibly difficult part
of the equation so you all are familiar
maybe with the Lake Ontario sort of
apple belt right that's like it's pretty
cool up there anyone driven along and
like miles and miles and miles of apple
orchards those guys for years this is
slowly changing because
the hard cider revolution but like who
do you think they were selling to mots
at what price
like 85 cents maybe 30 cents a pound so
for us to like even start to turn around
we need to charge $2 pads it gets a
little better when we just use it
in-house and then it gets a lot better
when we turn it into alcohol and put it
in a bottle which is not very earth
friendly at all and sell it and that is
the beautiful thing the problem is that
most cider e's are making their apples
out of the previous construct that I
just mentioned which is like extremely
cheap fruit and not very high-quality
fruit so there's like this messaging
going on about cider being awesome and
farm related and of course like cider is
farm related it's at some point comes
from an apple maybe except for the ones
that didn't write they're made from
malic acid and all this kind of weird
stuff and you can read that right on the
ingredients on the bottle so don't need
to like mention any names but there's a
lot of cider ease making cider with
really cheap fruit and dressing it up
really well and that is if you come into
the finger-like cider house like I hope
that you're going to get some glimpse of
what we're trying to do which is stand
for the farms whatever there's a variety
of stages so I'm just going to like kind
of puddle back and say what is the
finger-like cider house specifically
it's the tasting room that you must have
sent most of you have been into and it's
a tasting room for good life cider which
is from Grilli farm which is not an
estate cidery
right we are not a hundred percent
around fruit but it's very important to
us to be working towards that which is
why my crew is at home planting nine
hundred more trees right now and they're
like you are leaving what are you doing
and there's three other cider ease in
there Redbird orchard it has anyone
heard of them Eric is the Cornell
orchards manager here at Cornell and he
owns Redbird orchard cider they're the
smallest black diamonds
we're on part of them and marijuana was
a professor of homology here until 2013
and Eve cidery anyone heard of them so
she's actually the person that I met in
2000 when I discovered that farming was
cool because I worked for her and at
that I didn't realize she was like
almost my age she was 21 and I was 19
and I was here amazing you're ageless
like who are you and I feel really lucky
because she's been my mentor since 2000
and has been making cider that entire
time so she actually qualifies as one of
the longest-running sort of method Shemp
and masai therese in the country and is
very nationally recognized for her
quality and struggles enormous ly to get
the price that she needs to get for her
cider it's crazy
it should she's 75% her own fruit so
between the four of us that's the story
we're trying to tell in the cider house
and the Tiger has his own like super
conundrum of like collaboration is
awesome but not if the risk isn't shared
and there's a whole bunch of stuff about
that that has been very confusing but
what I keep coming back to is like if
we're trying to support small family
farms who are truly producing their own
fruit and paying like a lot of attention
to like what is the microbial makeup on
the skin of this fruit and how is it
going to make our cider really
interesting and really delicious we have
to be telling our stories loudly as some
of our competitors who have a marketing
budget any marketing person and who are
not paying almost anything for juice so
I think everybody showed us a lot of in
2014 when we presented the idea to those
other side erease they showed us a lot
of faith because we were saying like
look our farm is a great place for this
we can build the building we can find
the funding which is crazy that we did
and we will run the tasting room for all
of us on all of our behalf and over that
time it's become really clear to my
husband and I I don't know if you heard
in my story so far
is there any background in hospitality
that I mentioned any background and
classes no we had
no idea what we were getting into it was
crazy we were just like sure that we
could do it and I I was talking to
Stefan last night actually and it's
funny because I told him I was coming
here and he didn't tell me he'd give a
talk of course I was just like Stefan my
head is scrambled like help me what
should I say here's what he told me to
say he said say ask him ask me about my
business
ask me what inspires me ask me what
terrifies me and and then see what
happens and I haven't done that yet but
that's kind of where I'd like to leave
it at this point and open it up to
questions I hope we can have the rest of
this be and I didn't really do my slide
show I'm not really concerned with my
slide show at this point like whatever
I'll go through the rest of pictures if
you want me to but I would love to just
talk to you guys and I hope I kind of
laid out what our businesses are Paul
thank you
pointing their farm career that you're
in immigration sorts of realities
also cuz you ran into me at 4 o'clock
and asked me how I was doing and I was
like okay that's a great question thank
you
this continues to be what inspires me
this is a picture of my cow herd being
followed by my turkey flock and I feel
really really strongly about the kind of
agriculture we're doing and I feel
really really well educated about how
expensive it is to do it this is my
original cow herd there were three
animals in it and two of them were
female and one of them we ate and so
this is like yay yay
obviously I bought a couple more mom's
eyes in 2012 get to 18 just my own
breeding but um I feel like so my bet
this gives me a chance to say like my
people often ask me like oh did you go
to Cornell for soccer and I'm sorry Tom
but I bought was like no except only did
it because when I was an undergrad here
I took the only class that I took that
resonated the most with me was Tom what
was class I don't know if you know him
but he's my old advisor he's here and
he's my dear friend please raise your
hand
thank you he teaches a class called
restoration ecology and that was where I
was at for my entire career as a student
here was much more interested like the
natural world than the agricultural
world and at the same time every summer
I was working on farms I worked on
remembrance farmer to stick in stone I
worked for Indians not any tree cab
sorry what's the big picture didn't own
it anymore
the sister farm to Indian Creek that is
no longer sister farm anyway we're
autumn west what no in new field on
Shaffer Road like the James come and
started but anyway it's not a hobby of
cidery sorry and all that whole time I
was thinking like this is fun but it's
not a thing like people don't make their
money this way and they don't make a
living this way and certainly like the
people I was working for were either
still working full time jobs a farm or
part
time jobs are just struggling and those
farms have all evolved to be like full
family operations at this point but I
never really thought a Greek I just
always thought like restoration or
conservation and I think it was signing
out about permaculture that really
turned that corner for me and then
getting in lots and lots of arguments
with grain and vegetable farmers about
what jerks permaculture list could be
because I would say like ten years ago
the movement was in a different place
and it was a lot more antagonistic and I
think there's a much better recognition
from the permaculture side about the
value of these are small organic farms
and I feel really lucky Paul that I have
my animals to wake up to every morning
because what has evolved the Rio and I
would say yes my inspiration has
Warrenton because I've turned into like
a master administrator I do all the
marketing I do all the staff management
I have 17 employees I used to have one
I find the money I spend the money I
account for the fact that we have no
money and luckily I still have livestock
that's like my main thing is like I I
have to do the chores so in the morning
and in the evening I'm still a farmer
whether I can afford to be a farmer in
the middle of the day and I think as
we've gotten kind of pounded in the
cider house by attention and our lack of
experience
I keep really saying that people still
tend to but but maybe not because you
guys have all been there and you didn't
know about the good life farm but let's
pretend that what I'm saying is true and
then you can tell me it's not later
people know that they're on a working
farm to some degree and that that feels
different and that they see that we
treat our place like with a lot of
reverence and I think it tends to be
like one of the best educational
experiences a lot of people can have
which is why we have this festival which
is a Memorial Day weekend and then
you're all welcome to come it's called
it's organza and we've been having it
for six years because we planted two
acres of asparagus which is a lot if you
are curious it is four miles of walking
if one person has two
harvested by themselves can we never do
that ever I used to and I remember like
I had a mental breakdown once in the
middle of it and I walked away and so
now it's like a four or five person
thing and yeah I think what I need to do
better to keep myself happy is is is be
out there like giving farm tours and
explaining this to people so that that
proportion of hand-raising let's do it
again who knew about the Finger Lakes
cider house okay and before this who
knew about the good life farm ok well
that I feel like it was like different I
really do yeah I feel you're all
cheating it seemed to me like it was
like half I think we need to do a better
job with that because we want to connect
people to like the quality of what
they're tasting to something that's real
and something they can support and
that's like an incredible capitalist
construct right like that we would use
our dollars are purchasing dollars to
make things better for people and at the
same time like in the cider house it is
totally true for us like it is totally
worked out that way so yeah I decided
did that answer your question or not you
want to ask it again yeah oh yes right I
did i okay yeah um we had a picture of
it somewhere why'd you with your
pointed wanting it becoming more your
motivation to half working and brother
oh it's the same the same thing I mean I
feel like it was so from 2009 to May of
last year so not quite a year we did not
have a tractor and for a long time that
was fine this is how we moved grain
really big quantities of grain for our
turkeys and we moved our turkeys all
over the farm so this is like they're
feeding vessel and then on the days I
would move it I would load it up behind
like in between the wheels and move it
and the turkey is like yes this is so
great we are so happy about this and you
can't see if they actually are fenced
like you don't invest that much and
livestock and then nothing
no they are and so I think that that was
like a nice system was very light and I
think I started to sort of feel like
everything we did was really like a
light touch one of the problems was we
were also touching our compost very
lightly which meant that we weren't
flipping international we're making very
nice compost and as we started to have
Apple pomace coming off the presses it
was like a legitimate issue that turn
into a rat problem and then we were
starting to get these bottle orders so
we made seventy five hundred gallons
which is nothing like it
last year it is how much does your son
making not that much you've so URI
capped out at ten thousand red bird
never makes more than three Black
Diamond made three and so it would make
use the biggest us the next and the
other two just like so much smaller just
for a proportion meanwhile like do you
have any statistics on wineries in your
head that doesn't touch the wineries
around here that's not even a small
winery like it's just and we're having a
very hard time like getting people to
recognize like a fifteen to twenty
dollar price point for our product but
where the hell am I going with this
oh right so the thing with always
wanting to do everything the hardest
possible way and the most
labor-intensive possible way is at some
point it gets really
offensive and you can measure it and
when we started really measuring it or
like losing out on the opportunity to
get really good freight freight rates
for our bottles because we couldn't
order them in a quantity because it
couldn't unload them that became an
issue where we got a tractor but and
that at that point I started to have a
separation of I would say direction with
my husband so at this point the horses
are my animals and I have to make sure
that they work the thing is that you did
everyone experience those rain storms
last Wednesday Thursday and Friday is
crazy
well I Reno - hey my cows aren't on
grass quite yet I'd be like wait for it
to get to a certain height because
they'll just mow it down right away so
to get hay out to my cows on Friday and
the idea of driving a tractor and that
is like you're committing to ruts for
the rest of your life right but I didn't
have to do that I was able to load it
onto this sled which is not in this
picture and get it out to the pasture
and no damage done so there's always
it's nice to have something that's four
footed you know like it can get through
anything it's an animal like it's like
you you can jump over a log like they
can jump over logs so we still have
legitimate jobs for them we've been we
pulled 200 locust posts out of our woods
over the past two months on behalf of
them we pulled out with the horses they
were in a creek you know are like in
behind a tree under a bush like really
hard to get with the tractor or way too
big for a human to lift onto the tractor
Forks I insist on doing the tillage and
it's like almost is doing her hobby
right now like her farm work hobby
because it's like half as efficient at
this point but the thing is because once
you have a tractor like you're you're in
it like you have a tractor why don't you
have implements for your tractor and the
lucky thing I feel like is we own no
implements for our tractor so at this
one we won't have a choice but that's
one of those difficult things where he's
he's going in one direction I'm going
the other and I basically I'm like well
they'll just be mine then and that'll be
my hobby so I don't know a little bit of
a challenge I don't know any any horse
farms
again correct me some wrong that are
either not split operation which means
they own a tractor and they do like
their efficient stuff with tractors or
that aren't supporting that with an off
arm job I don't know of a single one
does anybody yeah so I'm supporting it
with the cider house and it's a great
marketing yeah
like into the orchards yes isube
they are shot on blood out on farm and
then they're butchered off farm so
that's a very specific way to do it
which is called custom cut and we means
that we sign up all of our customers
before while they're still alive agree
on a cut sheet and at that point and
they pay a deposit so at that point they
own the animal and that allows us to do
that and it's a super beautiful thing
it's the only I I don't want to have a
hundred cows because I don't want to
stop being able to do that I really
really value the lack of transport
before slaughter so yeah I way too
intimate with my account it's really not
healthy
yeah do we want to see another picture a
really cute little guy
or did he go yeah they are so great when
they're and then like this is like just
born and I'm like hello Here I am let me
stab you let me capture you let me put a
tag in your ear and then like a day
later there's no catching just like
cannot get a hold of them so this is the
beginning of calving season so in our
farm like from now until the millage in
is like it's sort of like running a
sprint for the entire time it's like
planting trees picking asparagus
spelling it all delivering it all
remembering that the tasting room is
open trying to find the calves that have
been born and often when they're born in
tall grass like we try to calves on
grass there's a lot of finding them
involved running after them weeping and
catching them and that's like you missed
it if you're doing that some things are
too old but yeah any other questions
yeah
looks like everything how are you been
in there oh yeah like oh my god so I
actually texted one of my employees
because she's a master student in plant
science of science I was like will you
come I wasn't like really wanted to call
on her cuz she's been with us for two
years her her friend at a seminar um I
think that the naivete was actually like
a good thing in some ways because there
was like a fresh approach but there was
also like just a lot of really dumb
stuff about like how do we take orders
for food let's design a system like not
like let's use a system that restaurants
use you know and so okay what so we
think we're great systems thinkers right
like that is the entire concept in
permaculture it's not like we totally
screwed it up it's like we totally tried
to make it up from scratch but it was so
naive and it caused us a lot of stress
and luckily my husband and I worked
every Friday and every Saturday for the
first two years of that business so we
were there to take heat or to fix the
problem but can you imagine what that
did us to our farm I mean I worked
probably 20 hours not like managing but
like actually doing a shift so yeah our
farm really really suffered and 2015 was
a great fruit year it was a really tough
year for us like getting things picked
and remembering that's it like I my
sister came to visit in August and I was
like oh um I think it's but like the
vivid variety of peaches isn't ripe and
Matt is on vacation our farm manager and
she was like aha okay I think well I
think I work in the tasting for six
hours can you pick it my sister pixie I
mean you know it was just like oh my god
like what are you thinking like you have
to work these chefs like you should not
think that you're a farmer the whole
time you're in there like be clean be
ready and don't be stressed out about it
I think that's like probably anyone
who's ever worked in a restaurant once
like knows that right so I think it's
like hilarious now but it was enormous
ly stressful and I'm not saying it's
fixed but one of the things that Gary
and I realized is for us to do a good
job for armed
and for our farm like we actually can't
hold those shifts anymore
so as of January we don't work on
Saturdays anymore
mm-hmm ha ha but we come in all the time
ruffle everybody's feathers so yeah any
other questions so am I going over okay
I probably you're pretty young started a
little bit not so I started about an
ally your husband fun you love when your
buyers are and what was that like like
what's going into it was there ever that
thought of being young how do I start
this thing saying goodbye
there are a lot of people in here who
knew me at that time I so you guys can
feel I can't you were actually kind of
an [ __ ] but I think that we just
really thought we could and I think
honestly some 35 now I feel like there's
a lot of arrogance there and that so I
used to give tours specifically to the
permaculture design class that there's
one held in Ithaca every year and I
remember after one of them like I was
just really we just really got a handed
to us like constantly like we were just
so tired and so overworked and so
confused about like not our vision our
vision was very clear to us but we were
confused about how to maintain the rest
of our lives like this I keep coming
back to this because I really feel like
we we traded on this and one of the
things that really helped me stop
trading on that or like have a desire to
stop trading on it was to have employees
and realize that like I did not want to
subject them to the conditions I'd
subjected myself to and what it like
what did I want to be as an employer
especially in the tasting because you
could see it immediately like if if
you're stressed out and you enter after
the customer like everybody's stressed
out like it's terrible and so as I've
been stepping back from the tasting room
and are like from working in it and
trying to support my staff like I try to
treat them like they're the most
important for lack of a better way to
describe it like customer make sure
they're really happy and comfortable and
I think we were really really naive
about what we were going to need for
ourselves so we didn't manage have
children in those 10 years and all of
our friends has at this point and I'm
not saying we're not going to but I
think I feel like we made a big trade
and it's really clear to me at this
point what it was and I don't know that
I would do it again I'm not trying to
make this like sound terrible but I
don't think you have to make those
trades if you're not so silly about some
things one thing that would have been a
lot easier like to go back to this is to
buy a piece of land with like any
building on
like at all Oh like a barn like there
was a water there wasn't a driveway like
you know we really we can do it and care
it was like I'm a builder so like I
don't want other people's mistakes and
we were like great like okay it's all
great so you know like it's not like
this house was even for sale are
available and we didn't like turn that
opportunity down but most of the other
farms we looked at like at some point
we're like we're not going to look at
farms with buildings anymore because
that's stupid like why would we do that
he's like I don't want to renovate so I
think that was foolish like definitely
not having a place to live that was
stable but did that was the question you
asked me I think that was like really
the biggest mistake we still don't have
a place to live and also unfortunately
like this was designed to be our home
it's a third floor of this building and
we run into some really funny things
with the code officers so like yeah oh
that's my sister she comes and works she
doesn't work for me she just comes and
does what I tell her and that scares
brother by the way so one of the things
I think I've been remiss and not
mentioning sorry I maybe I should try to
get through my slides on is what a
family operation marek don't worry about
my slides
okay well that's carrot on the outside
matching and that's his brother and so
his family he's from Dryden his family
does live on our farm now so we build
our barn and then he built his mother a
house his mother and a stepfather and
they're at the bottom of our farm and
then his brother started his brothers
worked for us on and off almost every
year since we started and now he's our
cider maker and he's he was really good
at it and it's funny because I have
known Jimmy now since he was 18 and I
would not have told you 10 years ago
that he was going to be a really good
like award-winning cider maker but
that's like you know we kind of try to
remind people that we live in this
society where there's a lot of truths
and there's a lot of true partial truths
used as marketing and like what is the
what is this place and like what is true
about this place and I think that people
are tend to be very inspired by family
operations that are truly family
and I feel really lucky to have the
Millers as part of our operation my his
stepfather is a master electrician so
like today I was like I need a stove
wired in tomorrow
like I sorry I decided to do this event
we don't have the right equipment like I
found the stove but I'm not a wired like
can you come do and he's like yeah okay
I'll do that for you so you know that's
like that's one of the nice things and I
think we did know getting into that that
we would have some level of support like
that but I think we actually had no idea
the kind of support we were going to get
it has been amazing I would say like
Stefan and tor like I yeah the number of
people that have like randomly showed up
for us and said like we think what
you're doing is cool and we also see
that you are ridiculous and we would
like to help you in some way or another
our bank I don't know if anyone has seen
our commercial but we see yeah so
Thomson so now we're the poster children
for Tompkins trust because it looks
successful right on the outside
definitely people are like you were
successful I know like maybe we'll talk
about that in 15 years but we're a
really big client of Tompkins trust and
they wanted a heteronormative couple for
their commercial I mean yeah definitely
and then it turned out they kept
interviewing me and I have like a really
bad speaking voice went on recordings I
found like like I'm in a hole and I was
like you should really interview Garrett
he's much more interesting and they were
like no and i6y and they're like we want
a woman
as we go why I got it so we're we have a
commercial and I was me talking and it's
embarrassing
but it's very very beautiful they did it
I thought I did a great job so these are
the kind of things and they I think they
didn't like pay us for that but I feel
like they must give us every loan we ask
for at this point how could they say no
right so anyway let's see what else we
got that's Ellen my sister yeah fun so
this is what it looks like inside the
tasting room we do a lot of events like
this you can't really see this but one
of the things we're trying to do is we
started out two years ago serving 100%
local which means there were like
significant spices missing from our menu
like black pepper and there was a really
funny article written and tasting table
about us not using black pepper and I
was like that's what you got from your
experience here it's like the same thing
like Forbes came and they wrote about
the bathroom when I was like what oh you
wrote about the bathroom so you know
it's like our messaging right if you
have to constantly and I would say this
another thing we had no idea like how
you can't talk openly to the press you
must have a message and you must repeat
it like five ways you know and so one of
the things we're trying to do is serve
our food on our friends food that they
grow and we want to be a good customer
to other farms but we also really want
to elevate the fact that like Finger
Lakes food is amazing and we are trying
to put Finger Lakes on the map for cider
and for food the way Napa is on the map
for wine like that is what we're trying
to do and that is the purpose of the
tasting room and of any event that we
have this food pairing I feel like I
needed to say that any other questions
yeah hi
the land
creation and competition
well
we haven't been there it's really silly
at this point do you want to say
something about it I would love for you
to
[Laughter]
right then he wrote a book I don't
remember the name of that do you right
so he is a current permaculture star I
believe I could be wrong that he we
share an inspiration which is a new
forest farm in viola Wisconsin which is
where Garrett and I spent 2007 and that
was the first broad-scale permaculture
operation that we could find his 100
acres on this basically ridge and valley
like the Driftless area wisconsin if
you're familiar with it's like the lower
western part of Wisconsin and it's these
huge values and these huge ridges and
it's totally farmed for like it's
totally plowed even though these are
extremely steep slopes and what mark
would say the owner of that farm is that
it was where the NRCS wrote the book on
like contour plowing and I don't know if
it's true but he says and it's a great
point so he has been trying to replace
corn with hybrid chestnut and soy with
hazelnuts because originally that area
was savanna and when I used to have
presentations on the good life farm I'd
actually spend like ten minutes talking
about new forest farm because the
challenge that he was facing was he's up
against how many years of corn and
soybean breeding right and he's trying
to breed food crops on his own dime not
supported by you know the government any
schools and somehow compete against that
industry and that's like one of those
things is like so we were living at his
farm 15 years in so I'm telling you we
live in a shack they still don't have
half you know and he had two kids and so
I feel like that was like fairly
traumatizing for me actually it was like
like you guys seemed kind of unhappy
even though you're so inspired and
inspiring and now they're 25 years in
and they have dealt with some of those
things but that farm is still like it's
basically a test concept in a lot of
ways and it's a really important one in
icing
he's he's an elder in the permaculture
movement at this point mark Shepherd and
he wrote a really beautiful book that I
cannot remember the name of but I would
look it up and so it was like we came
away from that being like okay so the
idea is good and the implementation is
incredibly difficult we shouldn't be
doing any breeding we should be growing
agriculturally recognized crops so
that's how we ended up with the
perennial crop layout that we have
asparagus fruit crops I get much more
like those go to market in a really
straightforward way right even if they
go as cider but yeah I think I don't
know you made me feel like I should have
mentioned mark earlier thank you any
other thoughts questions I'm totally
just like ping pong like random never
should we see if there's any more slides
I missed mmm
yeah I think we're good yeah so this is
the this is the farm in 2013 these trees
are much bigger those are Asian pears
and this is again the inside of the
cider has a really strange font yeah
like I cut off the time we're done no
one has any questions
directly for the most part and I've had
so many big I've had a like a number of
big ideas that have truly failed
actually and one of them was this
collaborative CSA that we were running
and we just it was the same idea as the
food we serve in the cider house which
was like someone could join our CSA and
get a full diet because I was working
with all these other farms but we they
were such small producers we couldn't
get a low enough price to put our margin
on it to run that so that was two years
of really big challenge and one of the
things that's generated for me was a
really incredible marketing list so
between direct marketing turkeys which
was really easy for years and years and
running the CSA plus I fell like 400 or
500 of my pounds of ginger in one to ten
pound units directly to people and then
I mean we grow 3,000 pounds so the rest
of it I wholesale and we buy a fair
amount of it and I'm not allowed to open
this like Cornell's all kinds of
regulations but I did bring this to
share with you guys and this is our
house-made soda we use about 300 pounds
of our own gender a year for this yeah
and then we make these shrubs but you
can also have these are for you
is there to look at a shrub who
justifies you a shrub is a very old
drink actually and it's related to
sherbert so my understanding is that
it's it's you middle eastern and origin
and it's a way of preserving fruit and
vegetables by macerating them in vinegar
and then straining like the the
particulate back out and using it as a
mixer and so it was very vinegary we
sell it as a cocktail and this is one of
the fun things about Governor Cuomo he's
been great for craft beverage and also
like a little confusing to it maybe
agree with me he's done this thing where
like any farm Blanc can serve any other
farm Blanc product so what you're going
to start seeing on the wine trails now
is like where am I like who made this
stuff you know that's how I feel about
it but at the same time we're going to
probably start selling vodka gin in the
shrubbery because we have a shrubbery
which is a cooler where we sell shrubs
and we probably are going to serve
cocktails because I don't want to go
there but it's mostly a really
cocktail mixer and a lot of people also
when they are quitting drinking buy it
so that they can have something fancy to
drink with their friends who are
drinking alcohol no no because this has
a CSA that we were doing a 100% our own
products with a spring CSA so March
April and May because we have all of
these tunnels like six of them and this
is what we produce but the thing was
that that even with that much of our own
production like there was still so much
unpredictability in terms of what's
going to bolt and you're going to like
all this and have nothing for the CSA
this week which was always very
stressful and always happen at the end
of April and I was like why did I do
this
like I was so dumb and so we just went
back to wholesaling our green super
straightforward but I think that the
thing about the CSA was like we would do
you pick strawberries at the very end of
it people like loved coming to our farm
and that's a really important thing that
I'm still trying to figure out how to
offer that and I think that the cider
house is a great a great vehicle for
that
and it can it can justify it in a way
that as a farmer just being a good host
can be very very difficult because
you're like I'm wasting my time like
literally right now you know whereas
it's a cider house like being a good
host is an imperative part of that of
that job and it's been a helpful shift
for me
so this vision I only did it once this
year I didn't we had a sight orchard
with sale in January where I was like
come whatever drink I don't care but I'm
going to be out driving my horses in
circles and I'm going to give your kids
rides on my sled and it was so much fun
and it actually did turn into people
wanting to go in and drink in the cider
house and I think that's a nice place to
like back off and not try to exert
control which is kind of what we do at a
spare again is like you can come and
spend no money and that's like totally
fine we want you to appreciate what
we're doing here and we want you have
fun and one should be safe so we're
going to control that
and then what tends to happen is to like
I like this place and I think what you
do is special and sometimes I can afford
to spend money here sometimes not so
like yeah whereas if you're only selling
fetch in jur like you're only going to
ever get people who really really get
ginger which is a really small segment
hey a lot more people get alcohol turns
out so yeah any other questions feel
like you were trying to like get up and
stop me no questions no just like once
again for coming I know this is a big
company of you and again for the people
who came in late really happy you came
into the last talk of the semester for
us
yeoman hell is going to have other
events going on it's actually a mushroom
which I'm happy so exciting me right now
so the probably bottom is sunshine but
again right now is a different group but
yeah yeah we have some tea and cake in
the back teeth we feel free to hang out
for a bit I'm gonna put the ginger ear
back there yeah yeah we're sounds like
just what we tell me thankfully the
honey today this has been a production
of Cornell University on the web at
Cornell edu